well today I think it's very important
to engage this next generation in the
political process because our democracy
really depends on people participating
and if we can get them excited and
involved in politics and government and
public service then that's going to be
critical to the future of the country
well one of the things that i think i
have done is to be a role model for
women in politics i was the 14th woman
elected governor in this country and
what i hear from young women in
particular is that they recognize
because there have been women who have
gotten elected to office that they have
options today that they might not have
realized they had 20 or 30 years ago and
so i think that's very important i think
it's important for us to have women
participating in the political process
because we have different life
experiences we have different
perspectives on things they're not
better or worse than men's but they're
different and when women are at the
table the conversation changes whether
it's in a boardroom at a community
meeting or in a legislature and that's
important
you know I think what really changes
voters views of women is getting women
to run for office when voters are as
comfortable with women candidates
whether it's for governor or for
president or for the legislature or
Congress then they're going to be more
inclined to make judgments about who
they support based on the candidates
positions on the issues rather than
their gender and I think that will be
healthy for everybody
I think one of the the biggest
challenges today in America is the
partisan divide that we have in this
country and I think that's not good for
the future of the country it's not good
in terms of solving problems and it's
it's not good in recognizing that we are
one country and we need to to figure out
how to work together to resolve the
challenges that we face you know this
country was built on compromise it was
built on people being able to to give up
a little something in their own
interests for the interests of the whole
and we've got to be able to continue to
do that we've got to stop being so
partisan and start being able to work
together
well hopefully I'll have an opportunity
to serve in a policymaking position
again in the future and if not I hope to
continue to be involved in some way
watching my family having a chance to
see my grandchildren live healthy and
happy lives see them grow up in
communities and have the same advantages
that I had for a world where they can
still enjoy the outdoors hopefully where
we can address global warming a world
where they can get a good education
where they can have job opportunities
for the future I think outside of my
work that's what I'm most concerned
about